an investigation is underway into a
deadly malfunction at New York City's
fleet week festival a Navy SEAL was
killed after his canopy failed to open
properly during the skydiving
demonstration yesterday he somehow
separated from the parachute and landed
in the Hudson River the parachute was
found in a nearby parking lot and a
Warner is near Liberty State Park in
Jersey City New Jersey and a good
morning good morning crowds were
gathered here along the Hudson River to
watch that elite parachuting team the
leap frogs make that jump above the
river when they became witnesses to a
tragedy now investigators must try to
determine how and why an expert jumper
died down the u.s. Coast Guard and
emergency crews rushed in to rescue the
Navy SEAL who plunged into New York
Harbor Sunday after his parachute
malfunctioned during a US military
skydiving exhibition the seal was taken
to a local hospital in New Jersey where
he was later pronounced dead our hearts
and our prayers go out to his family and
I asked for all of your prayers to the
Navy SEAL community lost a true patriot
today after jumping from a helicopter
the Navy SEAL was somehow separated from
his parachute seen here which landed in
a Jersey City parking lot without him as
they were landing out of the corner of
my eye I saw a splash and I heard a very
distinct Thumba New York City has a go
on is the US Navy parachute team the
leapfrogs are the US Navy's elite
skydiving demonstration team they're
based in San Diego and made up of active
duty Navy SEALs and Special Warfare
crewmen what opera leapfrogs dive from
as high as twelve thousand feet using
smoke canisters flags and multi man
formations considering I have a son in
the military you know and for some day
you know somebody's got to report that
back to their family and it's
it's horrible the Navy has not yet
released that Navy SEALs identity as
they notify the next of kin Anthony and
a Warner so sad thanks Anna